[Musik]
da scheue ich mich sehr für mich ist es
jetzt drei jahre jahr oder so und ich
hoffe dass ich habe das auch gehört ich
habe gedacht die geilheit niemand hat
bis jetzt den play button zerschnitten
zerschneiden man den play button oder
trümmern ein player integriert was geht
ab und herzlich willkommen zu diesem
neuen video ja leute ich hoffe natürlich
geht es gut ich drehe dieses video
gerade mit meinem neuen hintergrund hier
also ich habe eben schon ein anderes
video aufgenommen vielleicht habt ihr
schon gesehen deswegen wundert euch
nicht warum der hintergrund der gleiche
ist ich bin doch jetzt die woche für
vier tage in österreich und kann kein
video dort drehen deswegen muss ich ein
bisschen vor produzieren und ich hatte
mir schon länger mal das jetzt als ziel
gesetzt und es wirklich mal
durchzuziehen und es vielleicht zu
versuchen zumindest in die nähe zu
kommen vielleicht ist es sogar ein
bisschen bisschen dreist dass jetzt so
anzugehen aber ich finde es eigentlich
in ordnung so weil ich ich muss erstmal
anfangen und zwar haben wir jetzt auf
meinem hauptkanal hier die eine million
abonnenten erreicht wofür ich mich ja
schon sehr oft bedankt habe und nicht
wirklich mehr gefreut hab also ich kann
das immer noch nicht glauben dass so
viele menschen meinen kanal oder so
viele unterschiedliche menschen jetzt
über die jahre einen kanal abonniert
haben und das schon eine millionen an
der zahl sind die mal da drauf gedrückt
haben das ist so kann und das war halt
einfach immer so eine marke für mich so
damals hat man immer so geträumt
irgendwann mal wenn du ihnen noch einmal
eine million abonnenten hast wird zwar
nie passieren aber stell dir mal vor
alter die wie krank so ich weiß noch wie
ich damals hier vor dem fenster stand
als 100.000 hatte und habe mir gedacht
alter 100.000 damit hast du nie im leben
gerechnet so ist einfach einfach heftig
so ich weiß noch wo ich damals 2000 hat
oder so in mir und mich schon gefühlt
habe wie der grösste ging so nicht dass
ich mich jetzt fühle wie wie sonst wer
hat man man lernt ja auch dazu mit der
zeit aber ich habe damals so wo ich wo
ich sechzehn rund 2000 abonnenten hatte
dafür ein alter wert 2000 abonnenten auf
youtube so ich habe 2000 ich hoffe ihr
versteht was ich meine
und mit der zeit hat sich ja auch vieles
vieles verändert meine videos haben sich
entwickelt ich habe
mein content ganz umgestellt da wenn ich
darüber nachdenke was ich vor drei
jahren hier für videos hochgeladen habe
die echt super funktioniert habe ich
hatte eine zeit da habe ich fast jeden
tag ein video rausgeballert was dann auf
2.345 hunderttausend klicks hatte viele
videos damals haben sogar die millionen
erreicht was jetzt schon sehr sehr lange
nicht mehr so ist aber das ist auch dass
das möchte ich auch gar nicht also gut
was heißt das möchte ich nicht also
natürlich freut man sich darüber aber es
musste ich sein so also das ist alles
cool so wie es ist ich bin mega
zufrieden so was gemeint und ich habe
mir immer gedacht wenn du irgendwann mal
die eine million erreicht so jetzt von
einem jahr oder 90 von 800.000 dann habe
ich erst mal für mich für mich selber
das ziel erreicht was ich eigentlich
niemals für möglich gehalten hätte klar
jetzt seit einem jahr oder so denkt man
dann schon mal dran aber dieses ziel
dass ich jetzt erreicht habe ich kann es
gar nicht mit einem weiteren ziel was in
diese richtung geht übertreffen klar ich
könnte jetzt sagen irgendwann mal die
zwei millionen dass das wehr aufgehalten
aber das ist für mich gerade überhaupt
nicht greifbar ich mache natürlich
weiter so wie zuvor
ich meine ich hab mir jetzt sich auf
juli dabei der mir sehr aufträgt das
macht das ganze auch viel spannender für
mich man kann zu zweit ein paar sachen
arbeiten und dass wir weiterhin fünf
videos die woche geben jetzt kommen wir
aber mal zum thema hier ja worum es
eigentlich geht
da scheue ich mich sehr für mich ist es
jetzt drei jahre jahr oder so da habe
ich ein video gemacht das war ende 2016
glaube ich da war hat dieser trend 1000
gradmesser was ist das und das und ich
hab das ich habe das auch gehört ich
habe gedacht oh geil alter niemand hat
bis jetzt den play button zerschnitten
versteht man einen play button oder
zertrümmert ein playback abitur
ich kann euch hier gern mal einen
ausschnitt ein werden das ist natürlich
ein schlag erinnerung die jetzt
vielleicht ein bisschen kaputt geht aber
ich meine er ist immer noch da und ich
stelle ihnen halt einfach kaputt in mein
zimmer ist einzigartig ich will gar
nicht mach die augen zu ok
ja und mein play button so wie er jetzt
aussieht total zerbeult und so hängt
noch bei mir in köln in meinem zimmer
ich bin sehr stolz auf das singen aber
es ist halt einfach kaputt und immer
wenn ich das sehe denk mir alex wie
undankbar und du warst du dass du für
eine scheiß video diesem play button
zerstört hass der eigentlich so viel für
dich für dich bedeutet ich meine das war
die trophäe für meine ersten 100.000
abonnenten auf youtube dass das da hätte
ich eigentlich lieber 20.000 euro
verbrennen können als diesen play button
zu zertrümmern weil das steht ja für
viel mehr
und ja ich weiss ich bekomme jetzt bald
den eine million play button worauf ich
mich auch schon sehr sehr sehr freue
da kriegt einen ganz besonderen platz
aber der 100000 play wand bleibt für
immer zerstört und es war sogar noch der
alte es gibt jetzt wieder neuen aber das
ist mir gar nicht so wichtig mein
nächstes ziel ist es auf jeden fall
einen weiteren silbernen play button zu
bekommen
400.000 abonnenten 500.000 abonnenten
auf meinem alex v kanal der 28.000 auf
dem ich damals reaktionen hochgeladen
habe und alles andere alles was auf den
hauptkanal nicht gepasst hat sage ich
mal so und ich würde mich so sehr freuen
und ich bitte euch so sehr einfach
diesen kanal zu abonnieren
und vielleicht haben wir das ja schon
innerhalb von einer woche gepackt wenn
jetzt jeder der dieses videos einfach da
kurz darauf geht da sind auch neue
videos online da kommen jetzt mal videos
ich möchte auf dem kanal reaktionen und
so weiter machen auch wenn das ist
zurzeit jeder macht habe ich mir gedacht
so klar viele sagen jetzt ey du willst
nur mit aufspringen weil weil es gerade
im trend ist so aber ich meine ich habe
es schon oft erklärt ich gucke selber
mal youtube videos schaue mir gerne an
und warum soll ich nicht drauf reagieren
und nebenbei noch wie die sich für
interessieren content zu schaffen so
deswegen würde ich mit mega freuen
schaut euch da gerne die neuen videos an
die schon online sind und abonniert den
kanal und ich bin mal gespannt wann ich
das schaffen wir alle da die 100000 zu
erreichen und dann meinen neuen play
button zu bekommen das war eigentlich
der grund warum ich mich dazu
entschlossen habe mich jetzt hier
hinzusetzen um euch darum zu beten
bitten alle von euch die mich gerne
mögen und ich glaube da gibt es ein paar
von euch sonst hättet ihr mich ja nicht
abonniert ihr würdet mirjam jäger großen
gefallen tun wenn ihr einfach kurz
diesem zweiten kanal von jahren
und ich verspreche euch da wird ab jetzt
jede woche auch zwei bis drei war ein
video hochgeladen
ich gebe mir da mühe genauso viel mühe
wie hier auf dem hauptkanal der
hauptkanal läuft natürlich weiter so wie
immer aber ich möchte einfach noch was
anderes nebenbei machen ja und man muss
halt auch sagen fünf videos die woche
hier auf dem hauptkanal das sind alles
selbst gedrehte sachen das braucht zeit
das ist alles extrem zeitaufwändig und
wenn ich dann sehe dass ich irgendwelche
menschen hinsetzen einfach darauf
reagieren was was creator erschaffen und
da ihre meinung zu sagen das dauert 20
minuten dann meinetwegen das kleine noch
mal eine halbe stunde und und dass das
interessiert einfach die leute gerade
mehr
und da wäre ich dumm wenn ich sagen
würde dass du dass du das machst du das
machst du nicht mit aber ich könnte
niemals sagen ich mache nur das weil da
wird mir auf dauer einfach dieses
kreative fehlen selber irgendwas
irgendwas zu erschaffen
ein video ein richtiges video ja okay
ich hoffe ihr das könnt ihr verstehen
und wie gesagt danke nochmal für alles
ich habe bock auf den zweiten kanal ist
das ist mein nächstes großprojekt großes
ziel
hier hab ich jetzt für meine sachen
erstmal alles erreicht das ist für mich
abgehakt trotzdem bleibt es natürlich
weiter mein großes hobby und auf meinen
beruf hier videos zu drehen
und ja ich habe bock auf 2020 hat auf
jeden fall schon mal gut angefangen und
schauen was alles noch so kommt beim
zuschauen
ich wünsche euch was und 3